in puppets questionable displeasure
inefficient lies
dyn
do not
our country was deeply
hurt by a series of cases and
unfortunate events
the traditional means of communication
they are very attached to authority and they
reproduces the discourse of the powerful and
a counterbalance that is to say we are already in a
point from which we can assess whether
President's policies are
working or not
and the young people of this country are not
young people are not apathetic
they come and go to the extent that their
times and also the tools both
policies as social allow them
it is a fact that violence is
declining in mexico
the first seven months of 2015 the
denunciations for kidnapping has gone down 30.1
percent over the same period of
insofar as he does not accept what is
the current problems have been committed
a series of errors and hope that with
the same strategies are generated
different results
do not